donc je suis physicien ça fait plus de
vingt ans
travail ici sur le plateau
saclay je fais de la recherche pas loin
où laboratoire de physique des solides
seigne à l'université paris sud est en
gros bout de vingt ans j'ai une vision
de physiciens du monde qui m'entoure la
vison physicien c'est que je vois des
forces des interactions des particules
de la quantique des principes ce que je
vais vous raconter aujourd'hui c'est
comment ma rencontre avec des designers
à d'une certaine façon un tout petit peu
bouleversé cette vision de physiciens
alors d'abord vous n'allez pas y
échapper
je vais vous montrer ce sac de la vision
physiciens ont fait prendre la lumière
et vous expliquer ce que moi je vois
dans la lumière en tant que physicien ça
c'est une vraie galère parce qu en fait
j'y vois beaucoup trop de choses
il ya un grand nombre de points de vue
qui se superposent alors nous les
physiciens on est très astucieux on
prend un point de vue qui nous arrange
pour le problème qui nous arrange mais
tous les points de vue sont superposées
on va dire les uns aux autres c'est quoi
ces points de vue le point de vue le
plus simple c'est ce qu'on voit autour
de nous voilà il ya des spots là qui
m'illumine ou quand vous voyez un soleil
un peu derrière un nuage on devine des
rayons donc c'est un point de vue
géométriques la lumière ce sont des
rayons qui emplissent la pièce ici et
pouvoir faire de la géométrie sur ces
régions là et ça ça date d'un peu avant
l'an mil c'est les lois ensuite de snell
des cartes
ça vous rappelle peut-être des souvenirs
c'est l'idée que votre rayon pouvait
traiter géométriquement si rebondit sur
un miroir vous conservez les angles
s'ils passent dans de l'eau il est
légèrement déviée etc etc
alors évidemment cette vision elle est
très confortable on l'enseigne assez
facilement y compris au lycée les choses
se compliquent un petit peu quand on
commence à parler du 19e siècle et où
l'on découvre que ses rayons en réalité
sont composés d'onde
alors c'est quoi ces ondes alors vous
imaginez un toujours ce rayon qu'on voit
absolument pas et immatériel en fait ce
rayon la contient une onde une
ribambelle de tout petits champs
électriques et champ magnétique en
général perpendiculaire entre eux et
s'ils voulaient regarder de loin ils
forment une onde et alors on la voit
absolument pas cette onde je la vois pas
dans cette pièce alors que je suis radié
lumière parce que d'abord elle avance
trop vite
elle avance à trois cent mille
kilomètres par seconde et puis en plus
on n'a pas la capacité avec nos yeux de
voir ces vecteurs de champs électriques
et magnétiques se déplacer il va falloir
un sacré boulot pour les physiciens pour
se convaincre qu'elle existe ces ondes
et c'est ce qui fait maintenant toutes
les télécommunications modernes ont par
exemple déjà ces deux points de vue là
se superposent l'un à l'autre sont assez
complexes on rajoute un troisième point
de vue qui est le point de vue qui
apparaît au début du 20e siècle avec
l'arrivée de la physique quantique
lorsque dit la physique quantique c'est
que cette onde certes elle existe en
réalité les composés de toutes petites
particules qu'on appelle des fautes ont
alors cédé particules d'un style très
étrange à elle son cantique
donc c'est à la fois des particules et d
sorte d'onde mais je dois pas vraiment
dire le mot ondes je pars de fonction
d'onde une espèce de probabilité de
présence
en gros ce que ça veut dire c'est que le
photon il ya plein d'endroits à la fois
et c'est seulement quand on va essayer
de le mesurer qu'il va choisir un de ces
endroits se réduire soudainement en
quelque sorte en un point parmi cette
tente qu'ils occupent
quand on parle de dualité ondes
particules on a d'autres façons aussi
d'appeler ça donc c'est mon troisième
point de vue donc la voyez que ça
devient franchement compliqué les trois
points de vue se superposent mais moi
physicien j'ai aucun problème avec ça on
peut même rajouter les points de vue je
vous ai pas parlé de relativité
restreinte ou de relativité générale je
voulais papa je vais pas parler
d'électrodynamique pratique mais je
pourrais vous en rajouter des couches et
des couches et faire plein de textos
comme ça et le physicien il est très
fort aussi pour choisir ce qui la range
donc par exemple j'ai fait pendant 20
ans de la recherche en résonance
magnétique nucléaire dans des
supraconducteurs ça consistait en quoi
ça consiste à prendre un matériau
supraconducteur le met dans un cri aux
stades très basse température
et puis lui envoyer une certaine forme
de lumière et que cette lumière en gros
de test la réponse magnétique des noyaux
et donc quand j'ai essayé de construire
l'expérience qui permettait de faire ça
je me concentrais sur le côté
ondulatoire jeu calculer la longueur des
câbles qui nous palette ces terrains
puis quand j'arrive au niveau des
champions jose normands bien sûr ces
cantiques et là je m'intéressais à
l'interaction entre un petit grain de
lumière quantique et puis un atome de la
matière donc jongler avec ça sans aucun
problème alors où arrivent les designers
dans cette histoire là parce que l'on
voit pas trop leur place ils vont pas
mais des arts design et l'expérience
dans le laboratoire ni à refaire les
équations de la physique quantique
l'histoire elle remonte à une dizaine
d'années en 2005 2005 c'était déjà une
année internationale c'était l'année
internationale de la physique
c'était toute la physique et ça a été
une année clé pour beaucoup de
physiciens comme moi notamment qui pour
la première fois on se sont dit essayons
d'aller vulgariser essayons d'aller chez
pas dans une fête des sciences dans un
lycée tenter notre chance
donc moi j'ai fabriqué une petite valise
où j'avais mis pleins d'expérience de
physique quantique dans la valise
j'avais un bidon d'azac liquide dans
l'autre main que je mettais mon coffre
de la voiture et puis j'allais dans un
lycée dans le coin pour parler de ma
physique
évidemment je parlais pas de lumière ça
me semblait bien trop facile à l'époque
je me disais non faut parler de physique
quantique moderne et la
supraconductivité c'était un bon exemple
et puis de proche en proche on a
continué à faire ça on s'est mis à
quelques collègues on a fermé une petite
équipe de plus en plus de gens sont ont
fait ces interventions en lycée et tant
et si bien qu'en 2011 le cnrs nous a
proposé de faire une année
la supraconductivité c'était pour le
coup pas du tout internationale mais
voilà on sait inventer une année de la
supraconductivité est donc avec plein de
collègues on a fait plein de trucs
partout en france alors on organisait
des événements des conférences des fêtes
des silences des interventions en lycée
et c'est la première fois moi j'ai
rencontré les designers j'ai été voir en
fait une école de design à paris ça
plein si je leur ai dit voilà vous êtes
designers vous allez me re design est un
petit peu ma manip de lévitation
quantique
vous voyez une vision hyper réductrice
du design je leur disais vous allez
mambé lire ça et donc on a commencé à
travailler comme ça à dialoguer à faire
des projets ensemble
et puis on arrive en 2014 -la gens
commencent à en entendre parler pour la
première fois de 2015 année
internationale de la lumière
la shdm a dit bingo on va se faire un
projet avec les designers sur la lumière
voyez la lumière c'est un sujet de choix
à la fois pour moi physicien et puis
pour les designers évidemment donc
l'idée c'était leur proposer un projet
où il allait devoir utiliser la lumière
mais vraiment matières scientifiques
avec un discours scientifique derrière
qui était le mien et celui de certains
collègues et en faire un peu ce qu'il
voulait
à partir de leurs talents de designer et
c'est là où moi j'ai été bouleversée de
deux façons en fait la première fois
c'est le premier jour du projet en gros
donc j'arrive à l'école de design et
puis pendant une journée c'est moi qui
vais faire comme suit avec vous mais
pendant une journée entière pour leur
parler de lumière leur montrer des
expériences moderne leur montrer des
résultats et leur expliquer le point de
vue du physicien sur la lumière et en
fait c'est en faisant ça que soudain oui
je me décale un peu par rapport à mon
propre sujet et que je me rends compte à
quel point ce que je raconte est
absolument étonnant immatériel est
bizarre enfin faut dire le mot bizarre
moi ce qui me semblait complètement
naturel d'expliquer aux designers que
partout autour de flotte des particules
quantiques photons immatériel machin
avec des rayons et des ondes et cetera
et cetera
évidemment c'est déstabilisant pour eux
ni pour moi aussi en fait ce que je me
suis rendu compte de l'étrangeté de ce
que disait la science du monde qui nous
entoure
vous voyez premier étonnement en quelque
sorte provoquée par le fait que soudain
il faut que j'explique aux autres un
truc qui moi me semblait absolument
évident est simple une deuxième
étonnement évidemment c'est leur réponse
c'est à dire ce qu'ils m'ont renvoyé à
la figure une fois que leur effet ce
discours je vais vous donner quelques
exemples de ce qu'ils ont produit leur
premier exemple
lucile étudiante en design qui me dit
moi je suis intéressé par les matériaux
bear et fera gens j'ai un truc un peu
technique alors je lui dis mais pas de
problème ici que je vais faire un petit
cours sur la dirif range ans alors voilà
c'est ça la dir est france
donc vous reconnaîtrez évidemment un
polar isr qui orientent une onde
électromagnétique qui passent par cette
espèce de machin bleu gris qui est un
matériau bear et fringant en matériaux
guérif l'argent il a comme propriété de
modifier la lumière dans des directions
différentes c'est à dire que en gros
c'est votre lumière arrive dans un
certains axes il l'a fait aller plus
vite dans un sens que dans l'autre puis
ça ça dépend plus de la couleur de la
lumière et ça dépend plus de l'épaisseur
du matériau dont je fais tout un petit
cours là dessus et si vous voulez le
voir il faut absolument mettre un
deuxième polariseur derrière j'ai même
pas le temps de vous expliquer pourquoi
mais évidemment vous êtes convaincus par
le schéma
je m'attendais à ce que lui s'il me
fasse un truc très pédagogique là dessus
est un petit dispositif que je pourrais
moi même utilisé dans les lycées c'est
presque ce qu'elle a fait mais pas tout
à fait donc elle me dit ben pas de
problème je prends un polariseur donc ça
c'est le polariseur de lui s'il faisait
voir l'expérience va complètement ratée
parce qu'on est dans le noir il faut
être plutôt à la lumière du jour pour le
faire je vous préviens l avance et au
lieu de me mettre un bear est
franchement mais plein air et du scotch
le scotch est un matériau dire
franchement mais nommer des couches de
scotch avec des épaisseurs différentes
et vous avez vu que on voit absolument
rien d'intéressant pour l'instant car
elle me met une deuxième couche de virer
franchement moi je comprenais absolument
pas pourquoi me mettais une deuxième
couche moi ça me suffisait un bear est
franchement pour une expérience modèle
dans la deuxième se superposant à la
première avec des bandeaux si vous voyez
vous allez voir plein d'épaisseur
différentes de scotch un peu partout et
on voit toujours rien et elle me rajoute
le deuxième polariseur voilà c'est le
moment où vous voyez rien mais où moi je
vois plein de choses je sais pas si vous
voyez apparaître soudain plein de
couleurs étranges
oui quelque chose ouais vaguement ou
alors deux jours c'est sublime
c'est un kaléidoscope incroyable je me
mets là comme ça mais non match face à
la caméra un mois font fiche de vous
c'est la caméra qu'il est content bon
bref vous avez compris le truc
deuxième exemple leur parler d'équations
de propagation nous on aime bien montrer
les équations les physiciens faut jamais
faire ça en vulgarisation mais moi
j'adore faire ça quand même
et celle-là on aime vraiment bien c'est
une équation qui vous dit comment ce
champ électrique dont je vous ai parlé
se propage dans la pièce par exemple au
cours du temps et dans l'espace
et c'est une façon très synthétique pour
nous de décrire ça et donc je propose
cette équation à des étudiants de
l'école estienne qui est une école
spécialisée en design d'illustration
scientifiques notamment
mais je m'attends là aussi à ce qu'elle
me fasse probablement des dessins
pédagogique sur des ondes en train
d'avancer et elle me propose un livre
pour enfants donc là les enfants ils
vont être un peu calmés ils vont se
faire l'équation de propagation
à 6 7 ans donc c'est un livre en pop up
en fait vous êtes immergé dans le monde
des ondes
vous y voyez pas grand chose mais là je
vous assure qu'à maxwell qui est en
train de vous expliquer des choses vous
êtes immergé dans le monde des charges
électriques et soudain apparaît
l'équation vous la reconnaissez les
là-haut au-dessus de moi sauf que là il
est tout un peu plus élégantes et on va
vous expliquer ce qu'elle veut dire vous
allez être immergé d'horizon dans la
vous reconnaissez peut-être long
d'électronique si je tire à trois cent
mille kilomètres par seconde
je fais une simulation de ce qui se
passe et caetera et c'est donc mes
étudiants ont montré clairement décalé
en m'emmenant dans un monde d'enfance de
pop up de graphismes mais qui dit des
choses par exemple à la fin je crois que
le type serait bien dans son appartement
et se rend compte qu'il ya plein d'ondés
électromagnétiques partout dans le monde
qui l'entourent le wifi le four à micro
ondes les lampes etc
troisième exemple la physique quantique
donc là c'était avec des designers et et
notamment grégoire et grégoire était
très intéressé par la physique quantique
gonflé dire qu'un problème grégoire moi
je vais te faire un cours de physique
quantique et je vais t'expliquer à
chaque fois ce qui se passe quand un
photon tape dans un atome d'accord alors
il ya plein de façons possible qu'un
atome d'absorber ou d'interagir avec un
photon et une d'entre elles qui la plus
marrante à mon sens c'est celle qu'il a
moins intuitive un atom il peut être
excité alors non le dessine en haut ça
c'est des niveaux d'énergie ou pas
excité on dessine en bas et quand un
atom est excité si vous nous avez envoyé
exactement le bon grain de lumière
ça va pas l'excité encore plus de façon
absolument contre intuitif ça va le
calmer
ça va le calmer et en se calmant lui
même va recracher un deuxième grains de
lumière dont clash en train d'envoyer un
grain de lumière l'atome redescend ceux
d exceet et créé un deuxième grains de
lumière ça ce qu'on appelle l' émission
stimulée
proposé par einstein pour la première
fois et qui est à la base de tous les
lasers dans le monde le laser c'est une
invention de physiciens de la physique
quantique qui utilisent ce principe là
et là je m'attendais vraiment à ce que
le designer il utilise plein laser et
qu'ils fassent une installation à partir
de laser d'accord alors là je m'excuse
d'avancé pour ce que vous allez voir
c'est la réponse du designer à l'
émission stimulée
est ce que ça lui inspira lui
vous avez reconnu de l'athénée centre
le photon à l'évidence à gauche
la tendance était excitant
là les plus fins observateurs dont
plourhan remarqué la faute flagrante
les deux photos doivent être identiques
ne le sont pas alors moi j'ai dit à
grégoire c'est pas possible
et il m'a dit ah ouais mais moi les
costumes j'ai mis trois mois à l'hfr
poil par poil gelé refait pas autre
exemple
héloïse alors héloïse c'était une
illustratrice de bande dessinée on lui a
dit écoutez le ici tu veux faire une bd
sympa sur la science vient au labo et
passent quatre mois avec nous au labo et
on va te faire vivre des expériences de
physiciens et tu va raconter ce que tu
as vu étant infiltrés disons chez des
physiciens et en particulier on la fait
vivre une semaine au synchrotron dans sa
salle a marqué héloïse le synchrotron
c'est un incroyable instruments
scientifiques qui est juste à 2 3
kilomètres d'ici qui une ligne de
lumière en fait c'est un outil qui
produit de la lumière ultra puissante et
ultra propre et où les physiciens les
chimistes et plein d'autres
scientifiques viennent mettre des
matériaux pour les étudier sous le
faisceau de cette lumière
donc là je m'attendais à un discours
pédagogique sur synchrotron
effectivement il me fait une petite
bande dessinée en expliquant ce qu'est
synchrotron et puis soudain il commence
à dessiner des trucs qu'on plus rien à
voir avec ce que nous on sait du
synchrotron
mais quand on connaît le synchrotron ils
sont là aussi et puis elle commence à
dessiner les chercheurs eux mêmes les
signes clairs par exemple et raconte le
quotidien de claire clair c'est ce qu'on
appelle un local contacte donc c'est un
enseignant-chercheur là bas qui est
chargé d'accueillir les scientifiques
pour les accompagner dans des
expériences elle même est un
scientifique et en gros sa vie c'est
souvent un enfer parce qu'elle bosse
jour et nuit pour accompagner les
physiciens donc là c'est clair qu'ils
témoignent j'enchaîne 4 manip ce mois-ci
ya pas de temps mort c'est vrai que ça
fait beaucoup de boulot surtout que
j'étais d'equipe sur la nuit dernière
donc il faut que meurent décale
complètement mais ça va je suis pas
fatigué avec son collègue derrière qui
crée évidemment que c'est une menteuse
donc ça disait soudain quelque chose non
pas sur la science mais sur les
scientifiques et la façon dont ils font
la science et donc on a produit une
bande dessinée à partir de ça qu'on a
utilisé sous format bd qu'on utilise
aussi sous forme à disposition dernier
exemple
l'exemple de guillaume guillaume c'est
un designer aussi de l'ansea guillaume
on y avait fait tous nos discours sur
les trois points de vue sur la lumière
vous souvenez géométriques ondulatoire
corpusculaire et guillaume dit moi je
vous préviens ça m'intéresse pas du tout
de faire un objet pédagogique j'ai envie
de faire du design et donc guillaume se
lance dans la fabrication d'objets à
base d'illusions d'optiques de moirage
je passe me connaissez - ralph est passé
de bouts de bois l'un devant le travail
des petits trous et là soudain vous avez
l'impression de trajectoire
la dombes ici de particules et qui
s'était inspiré de nos points de vue sur
la lumière pour créer en fait un truc a
plus rien à voir
ce sont juste trois horloges avec un
tour complet par minute donc un objet
très élégant très esthétique de design
qui ne sert plus à rien du point de vue
de la vulgarisation et dont on pourrait
quand même se servir comme porte
d'entrée pour ensuite parler de science
un public qui pourrait par exemple est
réfractaire vis-à-vis de la science vous
voyez au bout de ce voyage avec des
designers des créatifs des illustrateurs
des artistes j'ai appris finalement est
ce que les hommes décale par rapport à
mon point de vue initiale à chaque fois
il faut une réponse qui n'est pas là où
je l'attend là où j'ai imaginé un
dispositif très pédagogique on m'emmène
dans un monde esthétique là où j'ai
imaginé un truc pour adultes on emmène
vers les enfants etc
ça a été possible uniquement parce que
dans cette collaboration on les a laissé
assez libre de choisir le territoire
dans lequel il voulait aller mais tout
en laissant libre on a continué à bosser
avec eux pendant tout le monde la
collaboration n'était vraiment sur leur
dos pour discuter science pour leur dire
là moi je pense que c'est faux vas-y si
tu veux là je pense que c'est vrai et
c'est alors ça ça m'a ouvert des
perspectives qu'on a on a construit
carrément un groupe de recherche sur ces
questions là à l'université et au cnrs
qui justement et bien créé ce genre de
projets de collaboration pour développer
des projets pour trouver d'autres façons
de parler de science et de physique et
ma physiques en particulier à la
physique de la matière la physique
quantique au grand public est également
on essaye maintenant vu que c'est un
groupe de recherche de penser ces
questions là et là pour le coup en lien
avec les gens des sciences humaines et
sociales
essayez de réfléchir à ce qui se joue
quand un public entend parler de science
entend parler de physique y compris à
travers des outils aussi étrange que la
robe de grégoire pour conclure
j'aimerais bien faire un petit plaidoyer
quand même pour la vulgarisation vous
avez bien compris que c'est un truc qui
me tient à coeur
donc la vulgarisation c'est formidable
et mon plaidoyer c'est que beaucoup plus
de scientifiques et de chercheurs de
laboratoires devraient y participer
et alors l'argument habituel c'est de
dire il devrait y participer parce que
c'est bien d'expliquer la science au
grand public c'est bien d'expliquer les
recherches récentes c'est bien
d'expliquer comment se fait la science
et pouvoir aussi engager un dialogue et
puis un débat je suis convaincu
évidemment toutes ces vertus de la
vulgarisation
il me semble que la vulgarisation a une
autre vertu qu'on oublie trop souvent
c'est que elle nous rappelle nous
physicien au moment on doit la pratique
et à quel point notre discipline est
incroyable vous y allez vous redonne une
capacité d'émerveillement vis-à-vis de
votre propre champ scientifique et moi
c'est vraiment quel est l'effet sur moi
c'est me montre à quel point la physique
permet de décrire le monde de façon
absolument spectaculaire et étonnante
merci